je suis impressionné par cette
assistance que jade hui et je suis
rajeunie en votre présence de quelques
années j'ai 82 4 ans c'est beaucoup et
bien en 84 ont fait beaucoup de choses
et il en a cité quelques unes et j'ai eu
le bonheur et le plaisir contribué à la
création de l'état tunisien
l'indépendance on ne connaissait pas la
tunisie d'avant l'indépendance la
colonisation l'a laissé dans un état
pitoyable on était quelques élèves au
lycée de sfax et à la sortie du lycée et
plus tard contre sont devenus quelques
milliers sinon quelques millions
d'élèves
il y avait donc l'ignorance et la
pauvreté aussi la colonisation avait
tout en main quand il a eu
l'indépendance tout était français les
banques les assurances les terres les
mines l'énergie des tunisiens étaient
pratiquement des étrangers dans leur
propre pays
donc on a et tout à faire à
l'indépendance doit faire à refaire à re
faire renaître l'état tunisien
la tunisie a quand même trois mille ans
d'histoire quand on fait le décompte on
voit que la tunisie a été pendant 2000
ans un état souverain indépendant
elle a été colonisée conquis et occupé
pendant comme m milan donc il y a une
forte tradition historique pour la
tunisie
et quand on parle de l'humanité le
avenir de l'humanité on se demande si on
peut faire des prévisions dans ce
domaine qui aurait pu imaginer l'état
actuel de la tunisie à ce que la évoluer
la tunisie a été carthaginois hannibal
america qui ont conquis la méditerranée
mais elle a été aussi romain pendant
quelques siècles et elle est devenue
arabe et musulman depuis quinze siècles
et se sont succédé des empires tunisien
cayron a conquis tout le maghreb et même
pénétré en espagne elle dominé et
ensuite elle a eu aussi et souverain qui
ont régné à madiambal fatimides qui ont
créé le caire lequel a été fondé par des
tunisiens
le général joffre qui a créé la ville du
caire donc il était important qu'à
l'indépendance ont fait revivre cette
tradition historique de la tunisie qui
était un état souverain
bon bien sûr qui aurait pu prévoir il ya
quelques siècles que la tunisie ne
renierait pas sur tout le maghreb
aujourd'hui elle est limitée au
territoire tunisien tu fait de beaucoup
d'événements historiques qu'on n'a pas
le temps
ici on pas parler ici aujourd'hui
que va devenir la tunisie difficile à
prévoir
aujourd'hui nous avons des atouts mais
nous avons des problèmes les atours
c'est cette force tradition historique
n'est ce pas qui a permis à la tunisie
par les temps qui courent de tenir le
coup de ne pas s'effondrer totalement
comme d'autres pays vivent cet
effondrement aujourd'hui
va-t-elle devenir dans le futur il y a à
la foire de l'espérance de l'espoir
l'espoir que les jeunes comme vous qui
devrait prendre en charge cet avenir que
les jeunes qu'on vous puisse cultiver
parce que ce que je constate autour de
moi et partout c'est que peu de jeunes
peut-être que je me trompe connaissent
l'histoire de leur pays
les absides par exemple levé le doigt
qui connaît les arbitres
la dynastie qui a mené trois siècles en
tunisie bravo il y en a d'autres moi
donc c'est ça le problème
le problème est faux que on peut pas
servir son pays si on ne s'intéresse pas
à son histoire
si on ne peut pas s'intéresser à son
devenir vous êtes le devenir
vous devez vous intéresser à ce qui l'a
été pour en faire mieux que nous cette
génération qui est en train de partir
voilà le premier point que vous voulez
soulevé avec vous
deuxième point important c'est le
problème économique
vous attendez de moi et cette réputation
d'être d'avoir vécu dans les conduits
depuis la banque centrale jusqu'à la
biac jusqu'au plan aux finances c'est
alger une vie bien remplie
houde attendait de moi que j'en dise
quelques mots ce problème économique
c'est le seul des problèmes qui se
présentent à l'être humain et qui ne
peut pas être résolu voilà je suis un
peu pessimiste à ce sujet j'ai enseigné
l'économie pendant une période de
traversée du désert parce que j'avais
refusé certaines attitudes on m'a mis à
l'écart pendant quatre ou cinq ans n'est
ce pas
mais j'en ai profité pour aller aux
jeunes et pour enseigner l'économie à
l'université et j'avais la première
année de sciences économiques à la
faculté il y avait le grand amphithéâtre
y avait 200 de son étudiant donc qu'ils
écoutent et religieuses voir ce que je
disais et je ne voyais que des cheveux
l'enseigné a des cheveux n'est ce pas il
était en train de prendre des notes pour
me les reproduire le jour de l'examen
alors j'ai dit à mes élèves poser votre
père porte plume s'il vous plaît écoutez
moi ne prenait pas de notes
la contrepartie c'est que je ne voudrais
jamais de questions de coûts et nous
avons commencé à discuter c'est devenu
vivant et on a abordé le problème
économique
c'était compliqué à expliquer à des
jeunes il n'a venait du baccalauréat qui
pour eux si tu fais l'école primaire
économique d'être ne sont pas habités à
ce vocabulaire économique
alors je voulais rendre la question un
peu plus intéressante
j'ai dit à mes élèves le problème
économique c'est le paradis
je ne savais pas comment c'est le
paradis le problème économique
j'ai dit l'éternel le bon dieu a voulu
leur donner un message à l'homme l être
humain en lui disant vous ne pourrez
jamais résoudre totalement le problème
est connu il n'y a qu'au paradis que ce
problème est résolu
il n'y a plus de problème d'équilibré
économique il n'y a plus de problème de
taux d'inflation n'y a plus de problème
de balance de paiement il n'y a plus de
problème de salaire une pluie de
problèmes de fiscalité ou la population
est stable
il n'y a pas de de problèmes
démographiques et
où tous les besoins des gens qui ont
réussi être au paradis sont satisfaits
sans aucun problème par la grâce de la
de la divinité
donc le problème économique c'est que
c'est une tâche c'est un travail
permanent etc des tentatives d'équilibré
toutes les données de l'économie d'un
pays
je disais donc que le problème
économique est difficile à résoudre
et il faut des plans des plans de
développement économique et il y a une
difficulté à convaincre les gens qu'il
il y a nécessité d'avoir un plan une
boussole le plan c'est en quelque sorte
une boussole pour s'orienter pour savoir
où on va et la tunisie à l avantage de
boue d'avoir jusqu'à 1 aux plans le
dernier plan qui n'a pas été exécuté
parce qu'il est la révolution et la
révolution c'est un peu devenu un peu
l'incertitude incertitudes et on navigue
son plan sans boussole depuis trois ans
on improvise l'impro ville l'a alors que
la tunisie a pu avoir une tradition de
de planification de développement
planifie rationnelle
ceci ne veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas fait
d'erreur on a fait pas mal d'erreurs
on a fait des plans n'est ce pas mais
c'est le pouvoir c'est le pouvoir
politique est des facs a été défaillant
qui a été défaillant parce que très vite
après l'indépendance faut bien le dire
l'autorité et l'autoritarisme s'est
installé dans le pays et a permis à a
fait obscurcir chemin devant les
planificateurs
et les plans ont été utilisés pour des
aventures dans le domaine de la
coopération généralisée forcer ce
qu'elle a donné la crise de 1969 n'est
ce pas et le drame qui en est résultée
et le pouvoir politique est devenue trop
personnel et aux vidéos et à mesure que
les détenteurs du pouvoir
spa du juge dans leurs prérogatives
on a commis des erreurs par exemple il
ya une occasion historique pour la
tunisie de jouer un grand rôle dans la
région la position stratégique de la
tunisie petit pays en cercle et par le
voisin de l'ouest et le voisin de l'est
voisins de l'est qui a derrière lui un
plus grand voisin vous la géographie ce
fut pas dire les noms et donc il y avait
un risque pour la tunisie d'être avalé
par les uns et les autres et le maghreb
et est ainsi constitué par deux états
importants qui sont donc coeur à l'ouest
et par deux états - d'indépendants la
tunisie et son voisin libyen qui était
pour l'indépendance ce déséquilibre
faisait que était un obstacle réel à la
constitution du maghreb
parce qu'il y avait ce déséquilibre donc
pour pouvoir faire avancer l'idée du
maghreb qui piétine depuis plus d'un
demi siècle
il fallait donc reconstitué un équilibre
à l'échelle maghrébine et ensuite il y
avait des tentatives de l'egypte 2
conques de s'installer en libye donc la
tunisie risque est d'avoir aloès
l'algérie est en reste là
l'egypte qui a acquis aurait fait
l'unité avec les livres voilà la
position il était important et bourguiba
et cette idée de génie qui
malheureusement échoué du fait des du
fait des disputes internes aux tunisiens
c'est pas la faute ni la libye ni de
personne c'est notre faute à nous ce
phénomène de dans les airs on se dispute
entre nous pour le pouvoir il y avait
des compétitions extraordinaire
bourguiba vieillissant chacun voulait
lui succéder l'espère et moriba cette
idée de faire l'union avec la libye qui
était l'idée géniale audacieuse mais qui
a été détruit par ses propres
collaborateurs
il y avait des luttes d'influencé entre
les responsables pour qui va succéder à
bourguiba et l'envolée être que deux
côtés de kadhafi l'autre nom du côté de
bourguiba et les ailes cet acharnement
fait que ça et jours et je crois que
l'histoire ne passe que je passe par des
plats souvent plusieurs fois attendrons
nous un siècle de temps encore pour
pouvoir avoir une occasion semblable
pour protéger la tunisie protégée la
tunisie contre c'est la vision une
mauvaise vision une fusion qui profite à
la tunisie c'était le cas de l'étude
était de pays complémentaires et ça
aurait probablement évité à l'arrivée
aujourd'hui des soubresauts qu'elle est
qu elle connaît donc ceci pour le dire
je n'ai plus que trois minutes qu'il est
difficile de prévoir l'avenir
vous avez j'ai plus de 60 ans que vous
essayez de vous de prévoir ce que va
être la tesi dans 60 ans si vous le
savez vous me le dites
n'est ce pas
est-ce que elle sera elle aura un avenir
meilleur est-ce qu'il va avoir dix
difficulté les tanks la période que nous
traversons une période difficile
comment va-t-elle évoluer il faut
espérer qu'elle devienne un état
florissant un pays heureux est ce que
vous le pensez est ce que vous pouvez
dire va devenir la tunisie ne peut pas
redevenir ce qu'elle a été
historiquement et qui a été à la tête
d'un empire mais elle pourrait si elle
était mieux gouverner et nous espérons
que cette révolution lui permettent ce
n'est pas encore le cas c'est pas très
clair on a réussi à faire une
constitution mais ce n'est pas la
constitution c'est son application qui
compte et c'est le désir des tunisiens
et des jeunes comme vous qui allez
prendre en charge ce pays de s'entendre
cessé de se disputer de cesser de nuire
à la tunisie par ces disputes
on peut avoir des opinions différentes
mais on doit les espèces les exprimé
d'une manière meilleure que celle qu'on
vient de voir à la nc
il ya quelques jours n'est ce pas on
pourrait - s'insulter - se disputer et
se comprendre et rapprocher les points
de vue problème aujourd'hui important
séparer la religion de la politique lui
parce que ça nuit au 2 c'est la religion
qui est dégradée la politique est
dévoyée n'est ce pas de la mêlée aux
disputes politiques et j'espère que les
dirigeants des formations politiques
existent qui comprendra cela est que les
pays qui ont réussi leur développement
ce sont ceux qui ont fait cette
séparation l'église catholique en france
après la révolution de 1789 a vu tous
ses biens confisqués par la révolution
hôte aussi bien confisqué par la
révolution c'est vous dire que ces pays
là on réussisse cette question à
résoudre cette question importante
il ya la liberté de culte mais il n'y a
pas la confusion entre la police
on n'impose plus rien en matière de
religion chacun est libre de voir ses
relations avec l'éternel j'espère que
n'est plus que 52 secondes pour vous
remercier j'ai été très heureux de ce
contact avec vous et je reste à votre
disposition merci infiniment